so I'm fired up for this episode of the
think media podcast we're going to be
learning about going full time on
YouTube and specifically as a musician
content creator our special guest today
is Sarah the instrumentalist and the
topics we're going to be covering is how
do you build your personal brand how can
you leverage YouTube to get your content
out into the world and also learning
about her creative process and how she
makes Incredible music and has been able
to monetize that in multiple ways and so
if you want to become a full-time
content creator in the Creator economy
buckle your seatbelt for this entire
episode because there's going to be some
powerful tips and a lot of stuff you've
probably never heard before in terms of
just what it takes to go full time in
today's world so Sarah welcome to the
show how's it going
I'm doing amazing I'm so grateful thank
you so much for having me today
yeah thanks for coming on and uh really
I'm excited for this conversation tell
us a little bit about your back story
and uh what it is you do as we kind of
look at your channel here as well
well I'm Sarah the instrumentalist is
instrumentalist by the way you've said
instrumentalists and that's okay I'm
just letting you every the whole world
know my name is Sarah the ocean
Mentalist and I'm from Raleigh North
Carolina I currently live in Los Angeles
California but uh basically my whole
life I've always loved music been a fan
of Music uh vinyl but uh growing up I
was surrounded by a very like everybody
around me was either a singer or
musician and uh basically influenced by
everybody going to church that singing
in the choir and when I was a kid I
actually
played in the band so I played the flute
the drums and I end up learning or was
self-taught with the guitar the bass the
piano and then when I was in college I
actually wanted to learn how to open a
record label so I decided to go to
school at St John's University to to get
my business degree so I graduated in
2012 and um at the same time I was in
college I was interning at
um marketing place called UD strategies
I interned at MTV and VH1 for video
production so I can understand like uh
producing
um in that aspect in that music form and
then I actually internet Platinum sound
recording studio for about two years
um to understand the Music Creation
process
um
I actually opened up my own record label
laude records in in college and then
I kind of was like when I graduated I
didn't really know what to do so I went
back home to North Carolina actually
started working at the Apple Store which
is like a a blessing in disguise because
you are basically kind of forced to
learn all the products and the software
like you know the ins and outs of how to
to actually fix a computer but also the
software so things like iMovie
GarageBand
um Final Cut Pro when somebody would
come to the store and they would have a
problem I'm the person that had to know
what I'm talking about so I took
advantage of learning the the you know
the platforms and
um while I was working there I was also
like
getting really interested into
instrumentals I found who kaytranada was
in J dilla and um
really was just inspired so I would take
my beat machine
um to work with me and then I would
maybe beat some of my 15-minute breaks
my lunch breaks and um just do it for
fun I didn't really have any intentions
behind it I didn't really expect
anything out of it but
eventually I made a beat tape and this
beat tape was called conversations and
it uh it got hurt by someone at epidemic
so I got um reached out and was able to
start making music for epidemic
sandwiches and music catalog for uh
content creators and the cool part is
during this time while I was working at
the Apple Store I was also co-workers
with a few a few YouTubers and one of
them was Tech me out
um Tech me out has a YouTube channel and
she um were co-workers and she I
remember the day she told me she was
quitting her job and I was like so what
are you gonna do and she's like I'm just
gonna quit this job and I was like what
to do what she's just like I'm just
gonna stay focused on my YouTube channel
I'm like
you could make money off of YouTube
I just been doing this for fun I had no
idea you can actually like earn a living
from it and
um so we would Exchange
knowledge we exchange information I
would actually allow her to use my Beats
and her songs
um and she would hang out and we would
make videos together and she would teach
me about how to use the camera and all
the cool things like Luts and you know
all the editing stuff and she also
taught me how to pitch to
um companies for uh brand deals
um gave me that confidence and and just
kind of just where everything matched
together I um when I heard about
epidemic sound she was the one that told
me that that's a great company I go to
them for music and it would make sense
for your music to be in their catalog
because you would get paid for it I mean
using your music and and then other
people can use it and and it'd be you
know and she kind of just validated that
that that was uh that this is a good
opportunity because I get a lot of like
random emails from random people I'm
just like I don't know who you are and
but um it was nice to have someone else
has already been doing it and me having
that conversation she's like yeah they I
go to them and if I can't find them what
I need from them I go to you and then
you might as well be in there and I was
like wow you're right and and it makes
sense because like I make my own YouTube
I actually started making my own YouTube
channel because when I was at work
people would ask me
what are you doing you know when I was
uh making beats on my breaks they're
like what are you doing I'm just like
I'm making beats and then I decided to
make a YouTube channel so I could
actually give people my YouTube channel
so if they want to watch me make beats
um because people seemed interested I
just started making YouTube videos about
it and then when she taught me about you
know there's there's certain ways you
can go about it and like actually have
this as a
um an income I was like oh I'm listening
you know and she taught me a lot so I
appreciate her and um and then it just
makes sense for me to make music for
epidemic because I was already making
music for my own content I was already
making music for other people's content
um it was something that I love doing I
never necessarily wanted my music to be
in a traditional form like on the radio
with a rapper on it I love just
listening to instrumentals and making
them so I didn't intend it to be
um
I didn't intentionally be like yeah I'm
gonna make instrumentals and make it a
living I was just like I was depressed
and I was going through so much stuff
and I was like I want to take my beat
machine out for the 15 minutes of the
break in my life and and disconnect from
everything and just like listen to music
and then chop it up and then you know
learn how reconstruct a song that I
enjoy you know so um
yeah
yeah it's such an inspiring story and uh
I I we love you music at think media you
know we've been partnering with epidemic
for a while and so Sarah the ill
strumentalist uh you've got a lot of
great tracks over here and um yeah we uh
for those who don't know I know a lot of
people maybe
um in our community are already epidemic
uh users a ton of people understand the
value and all the tracks there but if
you're new or you've never heard about
it before
um shout out to epidemic for sponsoring
this video you can actually get 50 off
an annual plan using Code think 50
um and also grab a 30-day free trial and
so anyways check out the link in the
video description and for all of those
in fact in fact shout me out on the
comments if you are already on epidemic
go check out Sarah's tracks there's some
um really great tracks on here and so um
I want to get into some questions about
the lessons that you've learned respect
to the creative hustle I mean you've got
your core art form of making music and
all of the time and Excellence you've
put into that but then you've got this
whole video creation side you're going
to cross 80 000 subscribers soon you're
gonna cross 300 uploads soon yeah I saw
that I was like oh that's a lot of
videos that's a lot of videos so what is
what is your uh video creation uh you
know shooting editing in fact let's just
watch a little clip here to see a recent
video and you can maybe talk about your
workflow and so from the viewers yeah go
ahead
all together well
well before
um it's weird to hear my voice it's um
before I
did this full time I would just make as
I would kind of just schedule my
weekends to to film and then like
throughout the week edit the video
um you know have like a routine I think
having a routine is super important but
specifically now like I've learned that
bulk shooting is really nice like you a
lot of the videos that I just post
um like the last three
and then the next one that's coming out
we're all shot in one day and then I um
if you go to my stories
um there's a bunch of videos where it's
like ways um like a series where I'm
like giving producers ways to overcome
creative blocks with the yellow you know
right there and it's just I've recorded
all of those the same day or I went back
to footage that I already had like this
is a conversation that I recorded of me
um in a mentorship conversation so I'm
talking to a one of my mentees and I'm
you know actually giving feedback to
someone that reached out to me and
wanted to to learn how they could up
their production game or content
creation game
um so I did all these things and like I
recorded like eight or I'm sorry like 11
different things in one day and then
throughout the week I'm editing I may be
editing a bunch of them in one day so I
know like
um I have content to post every day for
the next two weeks you know
um without having to like overwhelm
myself because I do want to make music
every day music's my priority and then
um I have a the intention to go live on
YouTube every Friday around two o'clock
so
um because music's my priority I release
music every week and because it comes
out every Friday and I stream on Fridays
I'm able to have
um like a listening party so I have uh
it's really like every week it's
something news new music and then the
music that I'm creating live will be
released at some point so the people
that are watching me live get to see the
process in the moment and then they also
learn about the plugins I'm using
um they're asking me about the equipment
that I'm using for recording because
streaming is like a whole different
level of
um production like I had no idea how
complicated it was to set up a streaming
setup like I'm using two different
computers I'm using multiple sound cards
and you know lights and you know it's
it's that's a whole nother level of
production that I had to to learn and
kind of just push myself into so it's
just um
I just now because I'm full time I have
a set routine and like I really try to
set certain time periods for certain
things but it's it's also fluid you know
you know we we don't want to have uh too
much
um we want to have Grace you know if I
can't do everything today it's okay you
know so yeah I love that advice and I
want to talk in just a second about
going back to maybe the transition of
whole time and and just that kind of
side Hustle season or working your way
there but before we get there I just
wanted to point out something
practically that's really cool and you
mentioned you recorded a mentorship call
and I see that you have this camera off
to the side
this allows you all is this what you
live stream from is this camera yeah
yeah it's one of the cameras that I live
stream from it's the main one yeah the
main camera off to the side you got the
the battery and a Sony cameras or the
continuous power
right but you're also able to
you're there's a lot of strategy in
there you're saying okay I'm gonna do a
mentorship call but if I record it from
the side then that's maybe I'm
delivering that advice to that
individual but then you have repurposed
that in a powerful way and I think that
um a lot of us here in the think media
Community could learn some insights from
how you've built out your workflow a lot
going on here but uh that's that's kind
of a cool tip to have a camera off to
the side like that so you can capture at
any given time take us back can I say
one thing about that so the minty also
asked if he could record his
conversation and I said absolutely like
I want you to create content around this
conversation I understand that you know
you have an hour with me but you could
have a clip like you can record a whole
hour and then have clips of me talking
to you and take those clips and and put
it on your social media and go for it
like you know I'm recording too so let's
you know so uh it's it's really nice
like you said like to kind of think of
it's kind of I'm doing two two things at
once you know yeah super smart uh I love
that now you're full-time now and so
you've got your YouTube content you've
got you've worked your way up you've
built up this incredible uh amount of
tracks and so those have compound I also
saw in your wall you got like these
Spotify plaques with what 10 million
listens or is it more than that yeah I
think um definitely like over 100
million streams right now on Spotify so
I have individual plats per for the
projects that it that have reached over
either 15 or 10 million streams yeah so
congratulations right now super
inspiring so it's a lot of different
stuff but you didn't start there and so
so many people watching this they want
to go full time
and what are some lessons you've learned
before you've like you kind of hit
momentum you know I know for me too it's
like once of course there's those early
days and you're putting out the best
work possible but you're kind of not
discovered yet or the subscribers aren't
coming in at scale because as somebody
finds one of your tracks now they might
find another one but the library of work
the almost 300 videos it wasn't there
yet so so what was that do you remember
what year you went full time and what
was happening kind of before that in the
months leading up and what you were
doing when you were juggling maybe
multiple things and any lessons you
learned in that season
so I basically went full time twice
um so I'll go back to the first the
first first moment for me is basically
when we when we are at work like our
normal nine to five and we take a break
most people tend to consume content and
I really think it's important to think
about the 20 80 rule so like it's okay
to consume content but 20 of the time
and then 80 of the time you should be
creating the content whether it's
um learning about how to do it and then
applying that into like you know pulling
up iMovie and then making your first
movie and your your first like footage
and that's what I did I took old footage
from like a trick that I took in college
and made my first video and put Kid Cudi
as in the the music and so look what I
did it's like a you know a cool way to
to Showcase what I did versus watching a
million videos and um and just starting
just literally just starting and um
but when you're you know on that lunch
break try not to scroll so much you know
put the phone down and grab your
computer and like open up those programs
that you're afraid to touch that were
free on the Mac like I I'm so happy that
they come with these free programs even
on your phone you have um GarageBand you
have iMovie you know have all these free
apps that are already native on these
devices and
um
just using your time wisely so like I
said the 80 20 rule like it's okay to
consume content but
you know maybe set a timer you know
maybe have some boundaries and for me I
only had 15 minutes so what I would do
during the day like when I was getting
ready for work I would listen to vinyl
and record the vinyl while I was getting
ready for work so when I would be at
work and go on my break I would listen
to the vinyl and chop it up on my
machine and then later on that night on
my last 15 minute break I would add some
drums to it and then the next day I
would add a Baseline and what this does
is kind of just allow me to make things
really quickly with the with no
attachment to it and then I also did a
30-day beat challenge because like a lot
of people get so
attached to their content or their music
so and then also you create a habit
after doing something for 30 days so
I decided to make a beat every day in
the month of October
um like in 2000 and like I don't know 18
or something and ever since then changed
my life because I've been making beats
every day I've been making videos every
day I'm always thinking of cool ideas
I'm releasing it and I'm letting it go
I'm not worried about the results I'm
just you know let's just make something
like and um
and just like being just having fun I
didn't really have any
like I really had I think that's
probably what what works for me is like
I didn't really
I think a lot of people when they go to
social media or YouTube right now
they're they're looking to get monetized
they're looking to get sponsorships
they're looking to get affiliate all
these things which is great but I didn't
know about these things I just did it
because I enjoyed it and I think the
passion it just trumps everything if you
don't have the passion because the it
did take me a long time to get to
a thousand subscribers I remember that I
remember asking individual people could
you could you subscribe to my YouTube
channel and I remember one of my
co-workers at um asked me how much does
it cost
I was just like it's free and um but I I
specifically remember these things you
know and I think you really have to
really appreciate each individual person
because when people see those big
numbers like a hundred thousand
subscribers these are individual people
and I remember getting individually like
to 100 subscribers because I needed to
get my name like YouTube slash Sarah to
Ill in order to actually have a URL I
needed to have at least
um a hundred subscribers and I remember
going around to each and every person
around me hey can you subscribe to my
YouTube channel
and and then and people I think so many
people are getting the plaques and this
that look so attainable to get
um these big numbers but it really takes
a while and and then it and I still have
been working very hard but I don't my
intentions aren't to get the hundred
thousand flat my intentions is just to
show my journey
um help a person along the way you know
raise vibrations make music you know
have fun and I I just it's cool to see
these videos like I remember this day
like
um you know and it's dope to go back and
see my journey and not just with my um
music but like me like I'm looking at
Young fair and like oh this is you're so
dope like you know like in this I like
to see other people's Journey so I think
it's just a matter of just doing it and
just being consistent and not really
being so attached to your content your
music and not being attached to the
results just doing it like because
you're passionate about if you're not
passionate about it then I'm like you
shouldn't figure it out like figure out
what you love and like and do it you
know
super inspiring and we've learned that
as well that uh YouTube and the create
create the creative life in general
um takes a lot of grit and resilience
and uh usually it's it's not like the
fastest way to make money you gotta do
it for the love you got to do it for the
passion but you also don't want to be a
starving artist So eventually of course
you have to pay the bills right for for
you what were the income streams that
eventually helped you go full time was
it a combination of Licensing or
royalties for music YouTube ad revenue
and what were some of those things at
that time for you specifically as a
musician
well there's a lot of ways to make money
as a producer at least right now
um like I said I didn't really intend to
to do it but it started to happen so
like I was working a full-time job
um but that's typical income but then
um you know working for epidemic sound
was a source of income which is
basically
um selling my music to a sync licensing
Library so they could use it for for
other content creators to have access to
it and um and then I received royalty so
over time these songs that are released
um I get I get paid you know and these
could be songs that I made a few years
ago so it's passive income and then
um you know as well as uh people using
my music I get paid for those things so
um those that's another source of income
from just one thing but I'm that's I'm
not limited to just working with them I
can release my own music so that's one
source of income
um you know we could release our music
right now for only twenty dollars uh a
year on digital kid and you could
release as much music as you want you
can release multiple bands multiple you
know artist names and um collect those
royalties you know
um that's when source of income and then
as an artist I think it's important to
have a YouTube channel so when you have
a YouTube channel when you reach those
criterias for monetization
um the AdSense is really nice
um but you know it's it's based off you
know the growth of your channel but you
can also sign up for affiliate programs
with Amazon today you know they allow
you to to as long as you have a platform
to host or the links you can have a
percentage of the cells that Amazon like
you you can get people to purchase
through Amazon
um and then there's other affiliate
programs I know Walmart has one I think
Best Buy may have one
um and when you when you you have the
opportunity to reach out to brands that
you want to collaborate with
um
by just going to the website and finding
their content their contact information
to reach out and pitch to them
eventually when people start reaching
out to you
um that's when you can start asking what
their rate is to produce and edit and
promote videos so that's a source of
income so like sponsorships
um another source of re
another income source is
you know we have the YouTube channel as
an artist we have
we hope to continue social media
platforms to pay influencers I I was
hoping that was going to be one but that
just went away with uh Instagram just
paying people for reals but that's those
uh you know Tick Tock um it's very small
but it's it is you know can add up but
as an artist I think it's important to
have your own brand your own website my
website is noquantize.com basically it's
not just about me it's a it's a music
production or music producer Lifestyle
brand that focuses on helping music
producers so I I you know I have
merchandise that that is really cool but
I also have courses I have the SP 404
MK2 course
um I have a machine course and then I
have mentorship opportunities so if you
want to have a one-to-one chat with me
to to maybe understand how I can help
you along your journey I also sell sound
packs for producers to use for when
they're making music
uh but this is this is honestly one of
the biggest sources of income and I'm
super just grateful now to to fully be
full-time because I have so many great
ideas to produce so many courses to help
produce this there's a lot of people
that need help and I've I've had years
of experience doing YouTube doing
um production for sync licensing for um
you know everything that I'm doing even
down to um
even rug making I just like there's a I
make rugs like as a hobby and it's it's
very uh satisfying but it does it is
that's another source of income like it
just uh
um making custom rugs it doesn't have to
be music you know rugs it could be rugs
for you know
for people that want certain things you
know and I could create a course around
that and that you know that that's the
source of income
um yeah there's a lot of stuff that was
a that was a major download of just so
much opportunity in the crater economy
and just just kind of income stacking of
a lot of different things that you've
been putting in the work for
um I want to talk a little bit about
your creative process in just a second
but I know that anyone who's watching
the video version of this has got to
know you're a dog person what's your
dog's name oh yeah that's Lucy
let me see my um
my mini Goldendoodle
she's my baby
and one of the tips I also caught from
you recently I was checking out some of
the um
the different stuff you have on your
website the different music packs and
whatnot and you you shared some tips
about kind of what's happening with AI
and oh yeah uh you were making some this
is insane cover art that you've been
doing using mid-journey what have you
learned about mid-journey and AI
mind-blowing I think is important for
people everybody every single person
right now that's living and breathing to
unders to at least try and understand
what's going on
um because
AI is not going to take over but someone
using AI is going to take over and I
think it's important for for people to
see the the shift that's happening and
it's it's it to some people it may be
scary but you know things not you know
everything could be some things would be
scary for some people but I think it's
important to embrace it and um take
advantage of it so mid journey is is
it's crazy right now um version five
blew me away last week when it came out
and I just typed in like
like um
somebody in a record store looks
searching from Vinyl and it looks like a
real person like a real picture and I'm
just like whose mom is this you know and
and I'm just like Blown Away with the
the intelligence that's that's coming
out of these these AI you know um the
fact that you can go at as chat GTP
could you help me write a script for a
YouTube
beginner's YouTube course and it'll help
me generate ideas or just a script or
you know um or I could say no that
doesn't work could you figure out this
and it'll be like yeah no problems and
I'm just like this is it blows my mind
because I was just thinking how when I
was a kid because if you think about it
children that are being born right now
they're going to be using this
technology they're not going to know
encyclopedias they're not going to know
um
they're not gonna know
um Windows 95 and um in Doom and all
these
um these you know Tetris and Pac-Man
they're not gonna know because it's so
obsolete it's they're going to have such
an advancement of resources that's going
to be mind-blowing just how like the
internet just came out you know and
people probably took it you know oh the
internet but now internet's everything
now and this Ai and the um the new wave
of uh web3 and all these these things
people are like I don't understand but I
think it's important to at least pay
attention
um and it's happening fast it's
happening so fast so yeah I'm excited
yeah uh some Loris watching live who
says AI is the future and I love what
you said that uh it's not that AI would
take us out but somebody using AI would
be the the competition we need to be
worried about so incredible tips in just
a second I want to dive into
um a little bit about your workflow and
how you have just developed your skill
set a little bit how you stay motivated
I know as creators we can sometimes hit
creative blocks or or uh you know kind
of have a writer's block things like
that and then maybe just your thoughts
on personal branding but
um today's video is brought to you by
epidemic sound and super grateful uh you
can actually grab this we were just
talking to them you know there's other
deals out there you may see or epidemic
works with all kinds of creators but
this is actually a really rare deal
right now to be able to get 50 off an
annual plan using think 50. uh epidemic
is uh it's fire I mean we've been using
epidemics now what I love we were able
to interview the CEO a while ago and
talk about
um just how much they put into their
artists and just how much creativity and
excellence in terms of Music one of the
most frustrating things about
like music that's usable in your videos
without getting copyright structs and
stuff like that is that a lot of times
the music's terrible but when you got
music that is world class with creators
that care
um epidemic just continues to deliver so
check out the link in the description to
take advantage of this deal and use the
code think 50 and you can check that out
and specifically look up Sarah the
illustrumentalist uh in terms of her
music on there but um I got a question
for you and that's
um
uh specifically
your tips for moving towards
Mastery for mastering your craft you
know when we look at your studio and all
the stuff like the skill set and music
that you've developed and you know cream
always Rises to the top no matter how
many cups of coffee you pour I think
what's important in the Creator economy
is like we actually strive towards
Excellence like I know that anybody can
get started we start messy but like when
it comes to music at some point the
Music's Got to Be actually great you
know and you've probably gone through
evolutions and uh you're very humble so
you probably are like I got a long way
to go but what are your tips for just
the True Grit it takes to become a
master at anything like you have done
when it comes to your music
consistency and showing up I think
that's the most important thing is is
having
if something's calling you hey I'm
getting a call music music music
acting acting acting you know whatever
whatever it is like answer the phone and
let it be a part of your lifestyle and I
think so like I learned that
before I would never I would be afraid
of saying I'm a music producer like say
hey I'm a music for this because what
follows up is people asking you what
where's your music
right right so you're just like um
I guess I need to make some music
so in order for me to to when people ask
me you know where's your music I'm gonna
have my Imma have it I have it right
there you know and it's and I got lots
of it which one would you like you know
and it's the same thing with other
creators if someone says that you know
I'm an up-and-coming actress well what's
where's your you know portfolio or
what's your whatever it is oh I got it
right here you're ready you know and in
order to be ready you gotta already be
ready so make sure that you're already
doing what you say you are so go ahead
and entitle yourself a video director or
a um whatever it is a music producer a
songwriter because when she starts
saying it you're gonna start being it
and doing it which requires you to start
practicing so if you think about Stevie
Wonder You Know
what do you think he's doing all day
he's probably playing the piano right
now and even though he's probably no one
he's maybe not performing for someone
but he's he's mastering his crap even
though he's like the greatest already he
and same thing for like if Prince was
still alive he's he'd be recording right
now he's like what's Prince doing he's
not sitting around watching Netflix he's
over there
you know recording or performing
literally or sleeping getting rest and
taking care of yourself and that's the
the routine like making the other thing
is is self-care I think is important to
make sure that you have a good mindset
your mindset is everything making sure
you meditate every day do affirmations
every day tell yourself who you are
before someone else says let's say every
day I tell myself I'm the dopest music
producer and then someone says you know
your music sucks and it's like no I'm a
I'm a great music producer because I
told myself that or if someone gives me
a compliment and says hey I think that
you're a really Dope music producer it's
like well thank you so much I've already
known this I appreciate that and it's
not going to go over your head or you
know
um or you're not going to be brought
down you know so the mindset is very
important and
um I'm a vegan and I think it's very
important to make sure that you're
mindful of what you consume not just
visually and like you know with your
your your ears but like what you eat you
know what you drink
every day
um because it reflects on how you feel
and then how you feel is how you you
know if you don't feel good today you're
not going to show up for that craft or
practice that you need to do every
single day you know so I think it's
important to practice show up and be
healthy and like be surrounded by people
that support you and if there's no one
that supports you be the biggest biggest
supporter for yourself and be the
biggest fan for yourself and be the
person that you need in your life
man such aspiring advice and I know that
one of the questions
content creators have and in the music
space and as a musician and as a
producer this could be more true it's
just a sheer amount of competition out
there how do I stand out
and do you have any just intentional
things that you do or any thoughtfulness
you have if you're looking at the
overwhelm I actually heard I think it
was one of the billboard Executives that
said
a hundred thousand songs are uploaded to
the internet now every day and then
somebody said it might be more and at
first it's like what and you think of
maybe about the mainstream but then you
start thinking about Lo-Fi stuff that's
out there and you think about songs
hitting YouTube and songs hitting a site
like epidemic sound and then and then
the long tail to SoundCloud and all this
other stuff so I think if you look at
that number it's a little daunting and
it can kind of feel like you're David
and you're staring out Goliath any kind
of crazy noise I always hear crazy
numbers like that I'm like oh that's
interesting
I I think for me personally like your
biggest competition is yourself
and um that's how I see I don't really
look at other people as competition I I
see as I think everyone has their own
journey and everyone's doing
things differently I can't be like uh uh
Curtis King I can't be like Tatro I
can't be like
um stolen drums like all these people
are on their own individual YouTube
music producers right and I think it's
important to um
like I don't see those people as
competition you know I think we can all
come together and and Talk Amongst each
other about how we can help each other
and and build more value within the
music production Community
um together versus like oh so-and-so's
got all this stuff and then I don't like
them versus or they're doing better
musically it's like no let me show you
how this
um worked for me because
um I had to go I release this and this
didn't work for me and then I released
this and it worked for me let me help
you because I'm my biggest competition
I'm looking at my stuff and I'm like
okay I've never done this before let me
try to do this and see if it works and
if it works you know great I'm doing
better than past version of me or if it
doesn't work like okay past version was
doing better and I gotta figure out how
to get to get back or get over you know
get better
um
so that's how like the numbers when
someone like someone said like a very
small amount of women music producers
exists and I'm just like
I guess like I I but I can't I can't be
everybody I can only be me I'm only I
can only show up as me and I I can't
change those numbers because I can only
show up as me you know and I'm I hope
that my show like me showing up
influences other people and other women
to show up as well
um but I don't see it as a competition
but it is is when you say like oh 100
you said a hundred thousand songs a day
I just I I
think it's just important to be a part
of that you know I don't think um so for
how I stand out is being myself and like
I said if I'm working on myself then I'm
just gonna be the bright brightest
sunshine and people have no choice but
to see me when I come around so
no that's that's incredible and
um it sounds like what you're saying too
is that you know from getting to talk to
you you really protect your focus you're
careful with what is occupying your mind
what's occupying your emotions because
you're absolutely right yeah I just I
just looked it up to confirm uh
Universal music groups said that a
hundred thousand tracks are being added
to music platforms every day I had no
idea but we often talk about that too
here at think media like if you look at
how many minutes of a video is uploaded
every day on YouTube or all these
different things it's kind of the wrong
thing you want to be aware of it but
it's the wrong thing to be focused on
because you also can reinforce the
information of we're seeing people all
the time uh Larry one of the people in
our community and just the short while
got a thousand subscribers in a week and
grew to 53 000 and I think six months
with posting 14 videos
um new people are showing up all the
time they really are new people are
showing up but of course working on your
skills being patient the Breakthrough
moment might be in six months it might
be in six years
um focusing on what you can control and
so inspiring for you to say the biggest
competition is the person we see in the
mirror really more than someone else in
fact
really it's more collaboration over
competition because the greater economy
is huge there's more tracks being
uploaded there's also more people
listening and the world's more diverse
and more unique in their in their
preferences and the styles of music and
sub niches within niches in terms of
different music so that's really
inspiring advice well as we land the
plane today if you're watching this live
I have a couple questions for you from
our community but throw four question
marks before and after your question if
you want to ask Sarah a question and
then smash like if you've been getting
value today we just want to send you
massive love and respect Sarah for just
adding so much value to our community
and super grateful one person asked
though as we were looking at so many of
your videos have you done a video on
your setup about how you're making
videos and how you're going live in the
gear you use
no not yet I think that is gonna happen
soon I think
I had to master it first and I think I'm
still finishing it because I just got
like a new little over the head brick
rig and I'm like oh
a new thing so um yes coming soon uh
definitely want to help other people set
up the live stream because it wasn't
easy I definitely want to shout out L
Dre and um Decap for having videos out
that showed their process because they
both use two different computers and at
first I didn't realize like
I needed two different computers and
what does that mean how do I set it up
you know
um but their setup is different from my
setup so everyone's setup is a little
different so I will share my setup soon
amazing also are you ever going live
over on tick tock
uh I need my
um Tick Tock uh was it the live the
quiche whatever the thing is called the
the
they give you a little keys so you can
stream live and I don't have that yet on
on Tick Tock I could go live directly on
my phone but um that's not the
experience I want to give people I uh so
I I highly recommend people to go to to
YouTube because it's it's it's more
helpful for me if we go to YouTube so go
to my YouTube Fridays around two o'clock
P
um Pacific and go live every Friday
yeah so these are all the streams on the
live tab on uh the Sarah to Ill YouTube
channel and so live every Friday and
definitely check out show notes and head
over subscribe to uh Sarah's Channel and
uh check out her tracks on epidemic
sound as well and all the other
resources that she's sharing uh we'll
link up there uh good question from
Circle H scuba and this is of course one
of the problems that epidemic sound
solves because you're getting access to
just premium music from real artists and
you're able to avoid copyright
challenges but the question is what are
your thoughts on dcma takedowns or ID
claims or fair use or copyright I'm I
imagine outside of the world of epidemic
maybe somebody takes your songs or songs
you've created outside any thoughts on
this category
well I have
I think it's very unfortunate that a lot
of videos get taken down or they get
their monetization taken away
um I have a lot of my my favorite videos
like the Rhythm roulette videos where I
go to a record store and I take I get
black phone did I grab three records I
take them back home and I flip the
records and um
before I upload them I actually you know
unlist them so I could see if they'll
get flagged but when they do get flagged
after and you know re-edit the whole
video or at least trim it down and kind
of just
you know I'm really I'm really very much
about the experience of people watching
and I wish I could give them the full
experience by playing the whole thing so
maybe I would have to maybe I'm thinking
of having a patreon page and they can
watch it there but yeah um that's that's
the thing it's like I don't like having
to
to edit some of the creative
moments that are very important to the
content like the final draft and then
something tell me like it's it's
someone else's and even one thing that's
frustrating is using certain samples
from certain platforms
um an example of splice and it's very
it's heavily used so some people will
they will claim that that sample is
their sample in YouTube Content ID so
with when any other person uses that
same sample whether it's in a stream or
if it's their their song that they're
posting on YouTube it gets flagged and
the person that that registered that
sample first is claiming that
monetization of course you could
um
you know you could dispute it and kind
of just tell them like this is a
royalty-free sample and everyone has
access to it no one that's
um shouldn't be claiming because it
clearly says in the in the um the
requirements and the YouTube Content ID
that it has to be original music
so um I think it is kind of frustrating
that certain people take advantage of
that and there they use it and then they
other people end up having problems with
just uploading royalty-free music like
from you know from sound packs for
places that actually are meant for
recreation whereas like if it is like a
a Michael Jackson song and I'm playing
the whole song uh I'm gonna get flagged
because it's not my song and I get that
so sometimes you have to trim the the
audio really small in order for it to
not get flagged but it's like I do wish
that they gave us a license to to use
um
you know because I created the content
uh we could maybe split it you know
Michael Jackson can get his cut I can
get my cut and we can all have really
Dope YouTube videos and
um and it also like limits my what I can
do on my live stream So like
um because my live streams go live I go
um the VOD or the video on demand goes
on directly to my YouTube channel as
soon as I'm done so I have to be mindful
while I'm actually doing live streams to
not have any thing that's going to give
me a copyright even though I'm live
um so I can't play vinyl like I want to
I want to be able people are like hey go
grab a vinyl like if I do that
you're gonna be the only one that sees
this video because it's getting taken
down as soon as we um you know and I
want to be able to keep my stuff up you
know I want to be able to give people
access because not everyone can watch me
live you know so those are my thoughts
about it
um Tommy asks and as a content creator
and artist of any kind once you put your
workout into the world certainly at some
point you might get some criticism so
Tommy asks how do you deal with haters
I think they're fun like like oh it's
it's my existence makes you mad that's
cool like I'm just I'm just being myself
and there's and I think the more that
you grow and show yourself you're gonna
get people that criticize you and have
an opinion
um and that's why I say it's important
to do affirmations every day so I have a
list of affirmations that I have on my
phone and I highlighted in my notes and
um
and then I hit the speak option and it
speaks to me and that's just a good way
to kind of start your day off to kind of
just set intentions for your day so if
somebody does have like you it doesn't
even matter if it's a YouTuber um you
know social media you could be driving
your car and someone you know gives you
the finger you're just like well you're
having a bad day keep going or you could
be like giving that same energy back and
then y'all are having a thing and then
in La people are crazy like you never
know what's gonna happen so you have to
be able to master your own energy so in
order to master your own energy you
really need to connect with your higher
self and it's like what's the what's the
best thing that I can do that's going to
be the best thing for other people so
someone
sometimes when someone says something I
may I may not respond at all I may go
ahead and block them
um sometimes I'll get you know correct
them and give them Grace and let them
hang out and if they continue to to be
disrespectful and I'm gonna just let
them go I don't need you around
um and sometimes there's days where I'm
like you're gonna you're the one that's
gonna get this today and because we're
normal we're humans and it's normal to
to to to have days where like someone
when you're driving and they're ah
you're like
is is but I think it's important to to
be aware like okay let me go and and go
take a walk or let me go
before I respond to this let me ignore
it for a day and then come back and be
like oh
you're having a bad day I'm not
you know so
affirmations 10 out of 10.
insightful asks was your music used by
Will Smith and so I looked up and I
found a video uh where you said I made
it Mom and one of your songs I think
right was on Will Smith's YouTube
channel has there been any other moments
like this or maybe YouTube channels it
always will it's been like so the thing
is with will like before I was even
making music for epidemic will has
started his YouTube channel it was like
a big thing I was just like oh my God
Will Smith has a YouTube channel and I
would hear the beats in the backgrounds
like who's these are those and and I was
just like it would be so dope to be
making beats for like Will Smith's
YouTube channel and then um when I got
uh pitch to do epidemic they had told me
like you could potentially you know be
in Will Smith YouTube video this
person's YouTube I'm like oh whatever
you're probably just gas me up and then
literally like one day I'm taking a
shower and I get out and my normal
routine I'll get on my phone and find a
video while I'm getting dressed or
something and the first video that was
there was uh Will Smith and I clicked on
it and the first thing I heard was my
music and I was like what the hell
like it's happening and um that's not
the first time like he's had like a
whole like multiple videos with like a
lot of my music just playing in it and
then his music was also or my music was
in his
Reunion Show for um Fresh Prince on HBO
Max which was really dope so I'm just
watching I'm literally watching it as
like a consumer oh my
God let me call my mom real quick you
know
um so it's been the other you know I
think honestly my music's been
everywhere it's been on Mr BEAST's
YouTube channel which is an honor
um it's been I feel like it's been
everywhere like on on all the you the
big YouTubers I'll be watching and I'm
like oh that's my so it's dope like look
at that
you know even like this week I'm trying
to figure out where my music was
um because I could see on my analytics
that one of my songs kind of just like
blew up in one day I'm like who's who
who had my video in there in their you
know and their content I have to figure
that out it's like a mystery sometimes
but sometimes I do know sometimes it's
like I'll I'll figure it out as I go and
I think it's really dope to um
to just be a part of people's
storytelling and kind of soundtracking
there their their life
I love that it's very inspiring to hear
especially as as a musician the reach uh
that your music has gotten out there I
have one final question for you from our
community
um but as a reminder you can um actually
grab a 30-day free trial of epidemic
sound plus 50 off the annual plan using
Code think 50 there's a link in the
description down below and you can
actually get access to Sarah's music
um over here so many great tracks and so
um definitely check all that out Link in
the description down below and I know so
many in our community are already
subscribers to epidemic sound and so
look up Sarah the instrumentalist
um and you can see all the various
tracks she has there plus so much great
music on epidemic
um the question I'm excited to land the
plane here because you've been so
inspiring and there's been massive love
and appreciation in the chat and if you
could if you want to say thank you to
Sarah also you know follower everywhere
but drop some love and smash like on
this video if you've been learning
something today and if you're grateful
but the cool g Jen asks the cool Jen
asks Sarah you seem so dialed and
focused how long did it take you to
shift your mindset and habits from
working full-time in a job I would
imagine typically to being an
entrepreneur
I'm not sure there's a time limit I I
think so the first book that changed my
life was the seven spiritual laws of
success by Deepak Chopra now I read that
when I was in college
um and after I read that I started
traveling everywhere and I had no money
I was like what's happening this is
great I'm manifesting
um so I got a glimpse into that world
and over time I would be influenced by
other people and other books and I think
what really helped me was reading Think
and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill and I
read that like in 2018 and literally
like that book is like day and night
like like a switch came on and uh life
has been amazing ever since reading that
book that one specifically so um
and I actually when and when you read
that book it makes you set goals and
have a specific date and be intentional
um I set a date to quit my job and I
told you guys I had quit or did left to
be full-time twice so the first time I
set a goal to leave my job by December
to have a specific amount of money so I
had that money by October
um but I got an opportunity from that
job to go to to LA to
um be a producer for the um for Apple
music
um so I didn't quit my job I actually
got a newer opportunity that which
helped me earn even more money
um and have a lifestyle that I actually
was manifesting
um because when I was out there they
helped me I mean for like six months I
had um housing I had food I had all the
stuff just because I was doing this
program and then once that program was
done I went back to the store and I was
able to then quit my job because I knew
I was able I was really ready
um but then they called me back to do
the the production for Apple music and
the Zayn low show full time
um as a contractor uh so I was like I
want to do both and I that was one of
the my other goals was to be working for
Apple music
um or iTunes when I initially worked for
um the retailers part of um Apple so
I did both and I think there was just a
Time
and I was very really grateful where I I
I knew I could quit my job and it's just
a nice it was a nice space to be like
you know I don't have to do this but I'm
doing because I love it and I did that
for at least almost four years I was
working full time with apple music and
then
um making music but then it started to
be like which one
like if I had to choose
but then music is my everything and I
was just like I have to I have to put
some I have to put my music first so I
eventually I had to just make a decision
and I decided um back in October of last
year to go ahead and just focus fully on
being a music artist so it wasn't
necessarily like
today I have it and now let's quit it
was like I have it
let's enjoy what we have in like when
the time I will know when it's time to
leave and I knew and it was perfect and
you know and I think for everyone else
you're gonna know when it's time to
to focus uh on everything but you do
having a job is a great you know way to
to have income especially right now in
this day and age you need money to to to
live so it doesn't hurt to take your
time that you do have to focus on your
passion eventually that time that you
focus whether it's 15 minutes will grow
into 30 minutes and then it'll grow to
half a day and then it'll grow to your
whole week where you get the focus all
week on that passion and you don't even
have to go or for someone else so just
focus like now use the time that you
have and then it'll expand into to your
intention of it being full-time
wow Sarah uh our create creativity tanks
are full inspiration is on 10 and uh
grateful for all the resources you
provide I would I want to encourage
everybody we're going to link up a lot
of stuff in the description of course
all of our resources website social
media and uh you can give a shout out to
anything else we missed we hit quite a
bit but I also loved that you mentioned
our particular Community believes that
lifelong leaders are lifelong Learners
we continue to learn and grow and we
love book recommendations and I haven't
talked about Think and Grow Rich in a
while I love that you mentioned that and
for anybody what can happen is if you
pursue that book there's like 10 000
versions and I want to recommend the
best one oh that's good to know yes this
one the Original Classic it's got this
this little pink uh kind of thing comes
off but just for our community we'll
link this up uh this guy right here you
can see it all marked look at it that's
right that's it and uh and so yeah the
nice pink inner cover but this version
of it you want the original some of the
mems uh are Abridged and whatnot and so
that was one that we discovered here at
that media but all that stuff we're
going to link it up in the description
down below and so any final uh things
that we need to know we're gonna put
post your YouTube channel your Instagram
how what can people do to follow you
connect with you and um see what you're
doing so basically you can follow me on
all platforms at sarah2ill on YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock Twitter
um you could listen to my music on
Spotify Apple music all the major
platforms understand the instrumentalist
and tomorrow March 24th I'm releasing my
first album that I've created from
scratch which means that I've composed
every single thing after finally
learning the piano I'm not because I'm
mainly a sample based producer
um it's coming out tomorrow's called
Sarah's keys so it's going to be on
epidemics sounds platform so when you
guys are making your new content make
sure you guys check it out and also add
it to your playlist it's going to be a
chill Lo-Fi Jazz hip-hop album so I'm
excited to to share that with the world
tomorrow so thank you so much for having
me and I really appreciate this
opportunity
Sarah we appreciate you drop massive
love in the comment section like the
video if you liked it and then click or
tap the screen to check out another one
my name is Sean Cannell rhymes with
YouTube channel this is the think media
podcast Channel and I can't wait to see
you soon in another one Peace and Love
talk soon